why do you think they let Tucker go why
do you think specifically on the fox
side I actually know why okay well they
were already planning to do it and then
um
let's just say this the Vanity Fair
article or the was The Hollywood
Reporter I forget which one was the one
that Rupert Murdoch was upset by his
fiancee being Christian
oh yeah I remember reading that word
because Tucker was talking about God a
lot in that speech and that it pissed
him off because Rupert is an atheist and
then Murdoch called the uh the head of
fox which said I want him fired and I
want him fired Monday morning don't tell
him until we put the press release out
simultaneously so they call him get him
on the phone say you're fired and then
put the press release out hang up on
Alex how do you know this and then they
won't tell him how do you know this is
it because people from I can't give
Source now I'm not giving no I'm not
giving names I'm not giving names my
sources are so good that I even I
haven't had Tucker's guys like come on
Alex don't tell everybody everything and
I didn't even get it from Tucker I got
some of it the point is I know
everything okay somebody like I got
stuff so incredible to blow you away but
I can't tell you